here's a question then like if you had
just experienced this through the hentai
would you have
would you have watched through the scene
yeah for sure for sure really i mean
most entire watch this story
really because it's like 19 minutes it's
not it's not a big ask
that's the most uncommon thing i've ever
heard because in the
history of this podcast okay you know
when you uh i don't know if you do this
right okay i gotta ask
when you when you're when you you know
you're doing your business or something
yeah yeah yeah
if you you know you finish your business
yeah
and it's like six minutes left do you
just save it for another time the rest
six minutes or do you just keep watching
to see what else
save it i save it yeah me too me too
i'm like i'm like i'm like this was so
good that i i don't want to spoil the
rest yeah
i'm i'm not i've never connected you on
such a like a spiritual level before
as you just said that moment it takes
restraint but i'm like you know what no
i could skip ahead and find the best
part yeah but no no
because you don't want to spot you get
you get so limited you know i've
realized with hentai it is literally
like you know
it's like mining for diamonds in
minecraft you just don't get it
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying no you don't get the good [ __ ]
it's like when you find a good [ __ ]
would you when you find one of the good
[ __ ] you got to save that yeah there's
like 10 hentai
that i can probably i could be like you
know what these are probably my favorite
that yeah
yeah but like they never come around
because because we have so much goddamn
ntr
it's [ __ ] it's awful at the moment we
don't get ntr
you know as much as i you know i can get
i can i can work with queen bee
but i don't like it where every single
non ntr is queen b yeah
honestly what is happening here can we
not do this for 10 seconds because i was
because just
imagine me when i go on to just like a
regular hentai website and i see
peace episode one i was like my time has
come
my favorite hentais finally what did
they do when did they come out uh the
dojin or the hand
hentai a couple years ago yeah it was
quite it's quite quite recent
i mean um i wonder i'm like is japan
just a head on porn like are they just
are they speedrunning it is this where
all porn is going to go to where
everyone in the world is going to be ntr
fans
god because i really [ __ ] hope not
because i feel like they're like five
stages ahead of like [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah i mean it's because japan just
accepts any kind of [ __ ] up hentai
right are we
is this what the world is going towards
are we all going to be ncr
are we all going to be in the office in
20 years here's the thing there's
obviously
someone out there watching ncr
a lot of people a lot of people i
actually know
someone i just shouldn't eat it
well there you go point point taken
you you literally the thing is it is
like you literally just proved your own
point
you know ncr you know sometimes is
attractive you know i will admit there
are one or two i'm like you know what
they had me in the first time it's not
all bad which ones but
i can't have the top of my head there
have been one or two where i'm like you
know this is good but then i'm like ah
it's ntr though i'm not gonna not gonna
do it
because i'm like you know what like does
this vanilla really have to die because
i feel like
vanilla is the minority of hentai that
we get now it's very rare
you just get a oh my they like each
other there's no
cheating there's no sibling rivalry
oh my god i think it's because in
context
japanese okay i think it's because in
the context of japanese
audiences who read it it's like why
would i read this when i could just have
it myself
actually get out there okay but like but
like with your vanilla thing
do you count for example step siblings
or step
parent stepmother whatever if there's no
other complications other than them
for some reason just being step siblings
or stepmother is that vanilla to you i'd
say yeah probably
yeah i mean that's pretty vanilla i mean
that's pretty that's that's probably the
most vanilla you can get nowadays
yeah i mean all right because the thing
is because the thing is it makes it even
rarer right because
you go on any porn website now it is
literally all
stepmom everything everything is step
really yes are you sure or is that just
the [ __ ] you look up
no no no i kid you not you go on this
[ __ ] and all the most viewed [ __ ] is all
step-by-step
and i'm like i'm like what is happening
i'm here for it but like when did this
happen i don't know when it happened
right
you know you know right like i see it
too i think melin can you search up some
of the most
searched terms on pornhub like because i
i guarantee i think stepmoms
in okay ashley ashley actually actually
i guaran
like i think it's either top three or
top five because stepmom is up there
what happened because i swear like five
six years ago lesbian porn was always
number one yes
it was never dethroned and then all of a
sudden out of nowhere in like the space
of two years
all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] goes to the top
what happened
in those two is this coronavirus where
people are like i just need yours pretty
good
um i'm looking up the most popular tags
for doujins
right now and uh would you believe that
milf is in the top 20. i mean
it's concerning no this is not a
celebratory moment i i will take my
crown
right now oh but then you know what
fellow degenerates rise up
degenerates rise up man there are some
like oh my god number 10 is shotokon
actually you're literally looking on
pornhub just search tops
just search god just touch the top
boss is sitting right next to you and
you're on pornhub
she told me to do it
what are you doing stop corrupting
ashley like this
what if the most search terms are like
it's literally they do it like a survey
yeah they do a survey they literally do
a survey and they're like uh
speaking of show to come should we get
on to the next one yeah sure let's go on
to the next one
do you want to know the 2019 number one
was amateur
number two was alien so those were the
those were the searches
[Music]
hentai is above lesbian now what
i swear it's like nearly like you go on
these websites it is like russia
driving half of this wait where's
stepmom
okay i'm milf though stepmon and milford
normally very like close
yeah yeah but also dude if you look at
it the amount of people in russia that
watch hentai is insane
really hentai is massive in russia it's
insane [ __ ] i need to move to russia
putin's like put mother knows best on my
90 inch oled tv
my my italian leather couch
or my polar bear rug
i'm sorry